in every eSport there's a moment you
know you've arrived whether it's making
top eight at Evo showing up on the main
stage of the International or getting
swept by a Chinese team at Worlds every
accomplished professional can think back
to that one moment where they were able
to look around smile and say with
absolute certainty I've made it now for
the vast majority of players these
moments are sacred true milestones in
their journey towards becoming the best
and in cs:go one of those moments
arrives when you punch your first ticket
to a major earning you the right to
design your own in-game sticker weaving
your name into the fabric of Valve's
busted-ass code forever but for one of
counterstrikes brightest up-and-coming
Australian talents it wasn't an
opportunity to be solemn and ceremonial
it was a chance to be cocky so the
team's expectations going in this
tournament we're pretty thick and pumped
right now to make a bangin first
impression I like me and decadent about
you guys in the desk meeting yeah yeah
okay meaty okay like nearly all of Olly
dick Stacey Tierney's moments in the
limelight it was an opportunity to well
dick around lied to be honest I feel
like everyone just loves a good dick
joke and I feel like people that say
like um it's immature or anything like
that I just taking himself too serious
and they take life too seriously my
everyone should love a good dick and
that's about it that's the end of the
story so what is it about big dick
Stacey that drove him to try to slap a
schlong on his major sticker how did he
kind of get away with it and how is it
forever changed the meaning culture of
Counter Strike
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so if you have never heard of
the esteemed mr. Richard Stacey well
actually that's pretty understandable
see he isn't particularly famous for his
play he's famous for his personality I
want to keep it clean I want to get that
people have applied a lot of pressure on
me this year I said we got a win so
we're gonna go to the best crack if you
wanted to keep it clean you wouldn't
have brought dick Stacey on this stage
that's not to say the dick isn't a great
player he's just you know a bit of a
prick
[Applause]
you see true to his name the only thing
that tickled mr. Stacy's fancy more than
csgo was well dicks dicks like a man
dick well I mean dick jokes you see like
a lot of those criminals from down under
dick stacy is rowdy rambunctious and
really into his own perverse sense of
humor
it's just Australia Nemo the some people
might not understand it can be a bit
blunt can be a bit dry sometimes but um
we're just like laughing at ourselves
and sometimes making jokes of whatever
we can we don't take life too seriously
Dan on the dick stood out as one of his
region's most personable and promising
prospects and only a year after emerging
in the amateur scene he joined his first
real roster Greyhound gaming by the end
of 2018 dick and the boys had poked
their way into a respectable number of
international events and despite almost
always finishing dead last were working
desperately alongside renegades to put
Australian csgo on the map of course I'm
standing here with big dick Stacey talk
to me about the team's expectations as
we go into this tournament so the team's
expectations go into this tournament I'm
a pretty thick and pumped right now
we're going in just heads up going
straight in that nice and hard and I'll
see what we got and deliver I don't know
if I could have said it any better
myself but of course we heard what the
Greyhound said let's go ahead and check
out what the other team said as well on
a competitive sense I think
counter-strike was a bit too late to the
show with that one
the Europeans named the American scene
had more money pumped into it an earlier
stage and we get outclassed by them just
due to the development their scenes had
and the support they have and what is
slacking behind and we'll always kind of
be behind unless we move over them big
dick Stacey had begun to blossom into a
sort of celebrity a walking talking meme
that everyone wanted a piece of so close
man somebody get this man a viagra
because dick Stacey's gonna have to go
hard he leaves the charge to the side
table it's already got him down even if
they didn't know it
they're coming up short they hang the
b-bomb slide but dick can drop the bomb
and just put a big hole in this round
but by the beginning of 2019 all of
dicks efforts had started to pay off and
it came to a head when he qualified for
his first ever major and now the only
man left he walks into the crosshair of
Malta and Kray how they've done it look
how happy they are 16 at 13 they take
this series two to one they're gonna
break the set as they become the second
Aussie team but joining renegades at
that new challengers stage man I don't
say a like the juice is just [ __ ]
flowing through me right now oh I'm just
too happy I'm over the moon now this was
big news for both dick and the
counter-strike community at large not
only was mr. Stacy's appearance on CS
gos biggest stage guaranteed to be a
spectacle but this member obsessed Nemer
had just been given license to design
his very own sticker it's kind of like
any cat attract players dream to be
honest you you play though this this
game for hours on end and getting a
sticker it's kind of like immortalizing
yourself in a game and I don't think
there's any better feeling than winning
that flying around in that qualifying
spot in the Asian Minor that the feeling
was just [ __ ] euphoric man it was it
was great I don't know man I'm just too
hard right now to now have a sticker
with my name on it made by me with my
handwriting it's pretty damn amazing now
whether it's through a major
qualification or a community capsule
getting your own sticker means something
revenue aside whether you're an
organization a competitor or a content
creator earning the right to craft your
own in-game cosmetic carries a lot of
cachet what's more it's usually
something that CS players take pretty
seriously given that some players spend
their entire careers trying to make it
to a major it means something to put
your stamp on the game you've dedicated
your life to needless to say dick Stacey
wasn't as dorky and straight-laced as
his peers and he wanted a sticker to be
a reflection of that because at the end
of the day who wouldn't want to slap a
big beautiful salami stick on a neikei
and go clap some Silver's with it I
think that's kinda just Who I am I don't
really take things too seriously
I think the serious aspect was me
actually
chiefing that it's up to me whatever I
want to put in there I don't think it
has to be serious I think the end of the
day the gaming industry is just no more
for fun and that's one to put in there
something that the community could
respond with in a fun way
so after thinking long and hard about
his very own major memorabilia
he hit valve with this rather daring
dong themed the cow naturally gaben
didn't bite and dick Stacy became quite
possibly the only player in the history
of csgo to have his sticker designs
straight-up rejected because it was too
inappropriate
I sent the worst one in first and I've
got no emails back so we should be good
boys should be good now a sane man one
who wasn't in a habit of self
identifying with a phallus would have
called it quits but dick Stacy was
neither of those things
thus in an effort to deceive the most
mythical and mysterious developer in
eSports he came up with a second draft
of his shaft the best part is that this
time he enlisted the help of his mother
well of to be honest my mom's always
been very supportive so I went to
Twitter to ask for suggestions and
inspiration for my artistic piece of a
dick sticker and my mum saw that tweet
she was just hey let me get involved I
was like yeah sure mom give it a crack
and then she's always had good
handwriting and came back and absolutely
nailed it with uh what she posted on
Twitter so while the community gushed
with envy over what an absolute baller
dick Stacy's mom was dick anxiously
awaited Valve's next attempt at
cock-blocking him and sure enough they
did dick began to despair speculating
that his signature might soon be spelled
out in the hellish unthinkable nightmare
that is Comic Sans fortunately it didn't
come to that and the so-called dick
stick out finally came to fruition my
sticker the original one the beautiful
beautiful artistic cartoon piece in
cursive writing
I've got rejected 24 hours before the
deadline they sent me an email
I was like [ __ ] what do i do what do I
do so this wrote in big bold letters
just the word dick so just like it's
what I am Who I am and
yeah that's chatted in there I thought
it was simple and quite nice although it
came out quite quite came out quite
skinny though in my opinion the
handwriting wasn't that skinny when I
sent in the paper that maybe they've
it'll drowned the sizing I guess you
can't pick and choose the dick sizing
can you it's beautiful
beautiful isn't it it's just so amazing
I just wanna hug it and kiss it it's
just incredible I don't know it's really
messed up anyway in spite of everyone's
immediate disappointment the sticker did
end up becoming exactly what dick Stacy
wanted it to be a way for everyone in
Counter Strike from the plebs to the
pros to harness a little bit of that big
dick energy and while dick and the boys
did end up bombing out of both the
Katowice major and the subsequent major
in Berlin it wasn't for lack of trying
Oh Mel talked it did it all I just want
to suck his dick tonight that's because
at the end of the day that's what the
dick sticker was always about doing the
impossible getting thick and pumped and
going deep and long even when no one
expects you to he might be all about the
memes but dick Stacy worked very hard to
get where he is and actually stands as
one of cs:go most inspirational success
stories what's more he fought tooth and
nail to help put his region on the map
made it to two consecutive majors and
contributed to Australian CSS coming-out
party over the course of 2019 and
although dick has been sidelined this
year by health concerns he took the time
to ensure that everyone in the community
knew how much he appreciated them
letting everyone know that his so-called
persona was actually a core part of who
he was to all the Google's out there
though think I'm his [ __ ] dick jokes
kept out this persona didn't suck my
hairy balls man that's I know it's just
myself so while the dick sticker has
definitely shaped counterstrikes memes
it isn't just some crass immature quip
it's a symbol of the unwavering
commitment and no [ __ ] given attitude
that turned all the tyranny into the
world-class competitor he always dreamed
of being and even if he never
makes his triumphant return to
competitive csgo he's literally left his
mark as one of the biggest ballsiest and
most beloved personalities in
counter-strike and that's a legacy that
he can swell with pride over my hope I
was a role model to a younger audience
to enjoy the process a bit more because
I feel like a lot of pro players get
caught up in results and performance a
lot and I feel like it's someone that's
young and getting to travel around the
world and to get paid while doing it
good money to be playing could be
against reliving and travel in the world
it's the dream I hope I was an
entertaining figure for that and showed
that this passion is something that's
very rewarding and such a good lifestyle
to have and I hope our people can chase
after it in a very mature way
so what is it about big dick Stacy that
drove him to try and slap a slap Jesus
schwäbisch long smoking smoking event
that's exactly awful
amenda deonda slap a big beautiful [ __ ]
on an ache a big turgid veiny
[ __ ] magnificent bastard